era uma vez um jovem formado em ciência
da computação que era um cara que não
era muito bom em nada ele era um cara
que era mais ou menos em várias coisas
mas não era nota 10 em nada
e pl assim como várias outras pessoas
ele tinha o sonho de ser concursado
então ele se mudou para concurso
ele ficou classificado em alguns
concursos e ele acabou sendo aprovado em
um bom concurso
ele virou analista de ti e do cepromat
[Música]
em um certo momento antes de ele ser
chamado para esse concurso ele teve uma
idéia de criar uma startup na área de
educação e ao longo de três anos ele
tocou as duas coisas simultaneamente
então horário comercial trabalhar no
governo e fora do horário comercial no
horário de almoço de noite seriado a ele
estava tocando essa idéia dele e que a
idéia dele começou a dar certo e ele
começou a se desmotivar um pouquinho ser
servidor público e em certo momento ele
falou eu vou largar do servidor público
e vou para minha empresa
todo mundo falava instalou no país como
assim e na verdade até a hora que eu
trouxe pra casa minha mãe quase enfartou
mais pois é ela sobreviveu
na verdade o meu nome é carlos pirovani
neto neto
segundo neto com 23 e eu sou esse cara
da história
eu vivi os dois lados então acho que eu
posso falar um pouquinho sobre isso
na verdade eu não estou aqui para julgar
quem estuda para concurso até porque eu
fiz isso e e foi bom enquanto durou e
tudo mais mas o porquê é tão mais
interessante você aprender a alguém é
que a esteja vendo este vídeo aqui no
palco a platéia não tenham um familiar
ou conhecido que está estudando o que é
compensado público eu acho que todo
mundo deve ter mais porque isso porque
nós somos ensinados com uma carreira de
sucesso
é uma carreira que de segurança
financeira eo concurso público se faz
isso
a frase do confuso e fala que escolhe um
trabalho que você ame que você não vai
trabalhar nenhum dia na sua vida é meio
clichê mas há algumas pessoas conseguem
isso mas a grande maioria não se você
parar pra pensar eu estava analisando os
dados ea 162 mil vagas dom estar aberta
neste ano de 2018 para concurso e o
salário ele pode passar de 20 mil reais
então assim acaba sendo interessante com
essa quantidade de vagas com esses
salários acho que quase que eu volto a
citar concurso brincadeira mas é bem
interessante a afinal quantas pessoas
vocês conhecem que têm menos de 30 anos
talvez ou 25 anos que ganha menos do que
cinco sete ou dez mil reais
poucas pessoas conhecem mas vamos
analisar isso pra que alguém estuda para
concurso público basicamente tem dois
fatores chaves e um agregado ali
o primeiro motivo é bons salários e isso
é ótimo a gente acabou de falar de
valores a iniciar muito interessante
o segundo motivo é a questão da
estabilidade e aí que eu sou eu para um
pouquinho nesse a estabilidade ela é
algo que faz a pessoa se acomodar
vamos pegar um exemplo bem prático na
iniciativa privada você contrata um
funcionário e ele não é um funcionário é
um cara que não produz tanto ele faltou
alguma coisa assim o que você faz quando
você demitir no funcionalismo público
você tem a tal da estabilidade isso quer
dizer que lógico que existem casos que a
pessoa saiba disso na via de regra eo
motivo também é muito bom é a questão da
licença prêmio e dos feriados emendados
né quem não gosta disso mas aí você
pensa essa questão dos seriados e tudo
mais que você imagina que você tá na sua
casa vai fazer qualquer coisa e é muito
diferente uma coisa da outra muito
diferente mesmo entendeu então o que
leva alguém a aaa
a fazer um concurso imagina o que pra
você gera valor você trabalhar por um
salário ea estabilidade ou por um
propósito o que faz você sair acordar
entendeu
eu conheço muitas pessoas quando eu fiz
o concurso passou muita gente era um
concurso na área de ti e eu conhecia
muitas pessoas que várias pessoas hoje
quando fazem com que o público eles
direcionam seus esforços pra passar e
geralmente os caras muito inteligentes
passam
o resultado são que profissionais muito
qualificados passam e chegam no
aparelhamento que é ele é engessado ele
chega com todo gás ele chega com várias
idéias mas chega lá ele é podado ao
longo do tempo ele vai perdendo aquela
vontade aquele tesão ele vai se
acomodando entendeu
eu não sou um desses caras fora de série
que eu estava falando mas só que eu vi
vários colegas que eram recém formados
que vieram da iniciativa privada que
tentaram implementar coisas novas e eles
trouxeram idéias novas
eles tentaram mudar processos tudo isso
com a finalidade de conseguir entregar
um valor maior conseguir a ser diferente
conseguir renovar e tudo mais mas que
acontece aqui eles não conseguiram foram
podadas ali e aí o que acontece é que
você vai perdendo e aí você vai se
tornar um funcionário comum com a cara
de funcionários públicos não há crítica
está acho que existem diversos outros
profissionais que são diferenciados que
trabalham pra caramba e tudo mais
e foi isso que me fez perder um pouco à
vontade e pedi para sair loja que estava
atrelado à minha empresa começará até um
certo destaque e tudo mais então com
isso é conseguir focar 100% e ficar full
time na minha empresa mas afinal o que é
ser empreendedor
a antram uma frase no site do sebrae
fala que empreendedores são pessoas
dedicadas corajosas capaz de correr
riscos calculados focadas persistentes
que estão sempre identificando
oportunidades ea gente sempre fala tá
isso é uma definição geral mais caras eu
não tenho todas as características
beleza também não
provavelmente não tem metade disso mas
eu tentei e eu estou conseguindo então
você não precisa ter todas as
características basta você tentar você
querer quem aqui nunca teve uma ideia e
tentou levar isso ela ou eu vou
conseguir mudar o mundo eu vou conseguir
ganhar dinheiro que seja
e eu vejo também muita gente comentar
quando a gente fala de empreender de
armas eu sou empreendedor seja porque é
meu
com 12 anos de idade eu já empreendia eu
nasci empreendedor tipo ótimo pra eles
eu não nasci empreendedor meu primeiro
negócio a estudar pontocom e eu estou
aqui até hoje então estou aprendendo a
empreender então a qualquer um de vocês
pode fazer isso qualquer pessoa
independente de idade de deformação ou
qualquer coisa ainda por cima eu tenho
um probleminha a que me acompanha há
muito tempo que é meio complicado que se
chama tdh um tal de transtorno do
déficit de atenção e hiperatividade
precificam ficando assim no lado do
outro
é isso acontece então por causa disso eu
sou um tipo muito esquecido
eu sou inquieto eu começa geralmente não
terminou mas isso não fez disse
tanto que eu estou aqui então tipo eu
enfrento mais dificuldades do que uma
pessoa normal mas eu estou aqui e na
verdade até que agradecer a ao meu sócio
minha família por cento e também
apoiando na verdade o que acontece temos
de ver se terei de empreendedores no
brasil e fora do brasil empreendedores
tradicionais e de modelos mais
inovadores o que acontece aqui imagina
se essas pessoas que empreender faz
empreender vai tirar o país da crise
porque se você está empreendendo você
está gerando a gerando valores você está
empregando pessoas empregando pessoas
você está ajudando você você está
ajudando seus funcionários você está
ajudando seus clientes você está
ajudando a economia porque se paga
impostos e tudo mais então isso acaba
sendo muito interessante também do ponto
de vista do mercado
a gente está falando de crise talvez
ajudas tirar a gente dessa crise
veja o empreendedorismo basicamente
existem dois tipos de empreendedores o
empreendedor por oportunidade e por
necessidade
no meu caso foi oportunidade no final de
2013 memória estava se preparando para
fazer o enem e alguns particulares e
também e eu vi que ele ficava muito no
computador eu fui entender por que ele
está ficando eu achei que ele estava
enganando meu pai minha mãe e eu no
facebook e coisas afins
e aí na verdade eu vi que ele estava
achando provas e gabaritos pra testar o
conhecimento dele e falei para ele
porque não posso automatizar esse
processo
sabe se que uma das melhores maneiras de
preparar para o enem e vestibulares
resolvendo provas anteriores porque você
se acostuma modelo de tecido de questões
e teste seu conhecimento
então a partir dessa idéia falei pô se a
gente reúne no lugar um banco bem grande
onde o estudante possa testar o
conhecimento dele entender o que ele
está melhor e pior e com isso direcionar
o estudo dele eu acho que a gente vai
gerar muito valor e assim surgiu a idéia
do sudoeste há cerca de um ano e pouco
nós mudamos de 9 nós mudamos agora pra
estudar pontocom
até porque a gente saiu só do lixo de
vestibulares basicamente hoje a gente
entrega tecnologia educacional pra não
trabalhando mas só com estudantes mas
entregando tecnologia educacional para
escolas universidades pra sistema de
ensino não só no que na verdade a
entregando toda a parte de gestão de
avaliação seja impressa online a e toda
a parte de gestão de desempenho então a
gente faz o cliente entrega um raio x
dos seus alunos as suas turmas das suas
séries
aí você fala beleza carlos não se está
falando que eu tenho que aprender então
quer dizer que eu tenho pedido a conta
hoje da empresa pedir para sair abrir
minha própria empresa não
necessariamente existe um termo que se
chama intraempreendedorismo que isso
quer dizer
você consegue empreender e inovar na
empresa onde você já está então isso é
algo muito bem quisto imagina que você
dá uma ideia ou vem com alguma coisa que
gere mais lucro ou diminua os gastos
dessa empresa gera uma economia isso é
muito bem visto quer dizer que você pode
ser promovido a pensar
todo mundo quer ter um profissional
desse seu lado não está pensando só em
fazer o que você mandou fazer está
pensando muito mais você pode ser
promovidos e pode vir a virar sócio da
empresa porque nao ah e outra
possibilidade também é fazer igual fiz
ao longo de três anos eu tinha dois
empregos
eu e todo mundo que acompanha todo mundo
dentre seus juros
eu não preciso trabalhar pela laranja
tem dois empregos como diria fechada né
mas então a gente está falando de
empreendedorismo eu vou separar alguns
motivos que fazem achar esse mundo bem
fascinante lembra começo eu falei que eu
não sou o cara tirou nota 10
hoje tá eu sempre fui na média vão dizer
que eu estou com oito e meio mais ou
menos outro ali um pouquinho acima da
média mas porquê porque eu tive que me
virar
era um cara que era totalmente cruelty
estudar eu tive que ler aprender e e
isso fez eu crescer quando eu comecei
com a empresa eu não sócio na época que
ainda não só a nós éramos formado em
ciência da computação então basicamente
eram duas pessoas que estavam no mercado
trabalho tudo mais mas a nós não éramos
tão qualificados
então eu lembro até no final de 2013
teve um evento em campo grande se
chamava pitt digital edição campeonao
era uma competição de algumas startups a
nível do centro-oeste e nós fomos lá e
eu basicamente tive que fazer essa
apresentação num palco tito isso aqui e
eu era um cara eu sempre fui um cara
muito tímido então eu sempre fui um cara
que até apresentar trabalho em sala de
aula dava aquela travada assim ela vai
falar pô mas não tem problema
o que aconteceu foi que isso aconteceu
lá também né eu travei eu tremi minha
boca secou não consegue falar mas o
resultado foi muito bom
a nossa ideia era boa da nossa nossa
etapa na área de educação da antiga
sudam baixas da pontocom e acabou que a
gente ganhou o primeiro lugar lá com os
estados do centro-oeste e a gente voltou
com um cheque de mil reais isso foi um
marco para a gente é sério todo esse era
desse tamanho é mentira nenhuma
quem quiser depois impede a mandar a
foto que ele está lá em casa
ah então eu tive que desenvolver várias
habilidades a aprender cada vez mais
então eu tive que estudar sobre a parte
financeira administrativa eu tive que
aprender a negociar a vender eu errei
bastante eu errei muito muito mesmo
até porque eu sou um cara que está
empreendendo na área de educação que têm
uma formação em ciência da computação
com a minha experiência pra isso mas
como eu disse eu vi uma oportunidade a
gente foi atrás
então fui estudar fui ler e entender um
pouquinho mais fui pra dentro de escolas
foi conversar com professores diretores
e aprende errando bastante porque é
interessante errar porque se tira da
zona de conforto lembra que a gente tá
falando sobre a questão em cima de você
tem estabilidade a estabilidade desse
estagnado enquanto quando você tem que
se você acaba tendo que se reinventar
tem uma frase que eu gosto bastante do
michael boyd
ele fala que todo o progresso acontece
fora da zona de conforto
a incerteza leva uma pessoa tem que se
reinventar
até que inovar ser criativo e é daí que
surgem as grandes idéias
imagina se é o inverso do concurso
focando ali a galera tivesse pensando em
como mudar o mundo solucionar problema
reinventar o negócio então é um pouco
disse que eu penso eu queria deixar
claro também a respeito de concurso
eu não sou contra nativa só tive uma
experiência muito legal mas a gente vê
aí pessoas que são funcionários públicos
que estão mudando o brasil a gente pega
sujo juiz sérgio moro por exemplo então
é importante que é a que tem um bom
funcionário estava repensando repensando
essa parte de legislação de burocracia e
tudo mais mas quero deixar claro que é
importante que tenha conversado não
briga comigo quando me chamaram para
palestrar no tedx no texas
eu fiquei meio eu fiquei muito feliz
lógico mas eu fiquei meio em meio a meio
perplexo
eu sou um cara na média assim é só um
cara tá certo
o estudo apontou hoje nós somos um case
aqui no estado
santi pensando em estar tap mas eu sou
um cara mais ou menos mas depois eu
parei pra pensar e acho que o meu caso é
bem interessante porque porque eu sou o
que qualquer um pode ser
eu não sou um cara genial não sou um
cara super inteligente eu não tenho
vamos lá vamos pensar em boletim ontem
10 em nada como eu disse vamos colocar
uma equipe média média tem 196 19 17 16
mas isso é interessante porque eu posso
ser o pedro maria josé o joão o cara que
tem pós graduação como o cara que não
terminar o ensino básico o cara que tem
50 anos só tinha uma ideia vou fazer
alguma coisa o menino que com 12 anos
está falando que tem uma idéia eu posso
garantir que hoje a minha vida é muito
mais corrida mas eu me sinto muito mais
feliz
o trabalho hoje com o que eu gosto eu
consegui montar e estruturar uma empresa
e recentemente a gente atingiu a marca
de ter impactado mais um milhão de
estudantes em nível brasil
então a gente está falando de uma
empresa de educação de cuiabá mato
grosso fora de um grande centro de um
eixo
até pouco tempo a gente não tinha
recebido nenhum tipo de investimento
então foi tudo na naka ali na raça mesmo
entendeu então a saber que estou
ajudando a melhorar a educação no brasil
me faz acordar todos os dias
a mentira é o despertador eu perdi um
pouco tarde mas era torcedor mas na
verdade a pergunta que eu faço a mas e
vocês com a proposta a motivação tem
feito vocês saírem da cama todos os dias
reflitam obrigado
[Aplausos]